JENI FISHER: Thank you,
Tamzin, for the intro.
So it's often said that
you are not your user.
As smartphones find their way
into the hands of billions
of users, your assumptions on
how people will use your apps
will constantly be challenged.
On one end of the spectrum,
you will find a new generation
of digital natives who
have no memory of a life
pre-smartphone.
On the other hand, you'll
find older digital immigrants
that are only now
coming to terms
with smartphones and the
possibilities that they unlock.
As we think about
how to build apps
for the shifting needs
and behaviors of users,
it's my pleasure to welcome
our distinguished panel who
will share their experiences
in building products for vastly
different demographics.
So we're joined today
by John Kneeland
from Bumble, which is a new
way to meet data network.
We have Kemal Ugur,
the co-founder of AVCR,
the developer behind Funimate--
a video editor and
creative community.
And Rojhan Ahmadi, who
leads product and is
the founder of NeuroNation-- a
leading brain training program.
So onto the first question--
do you feel that there's
a generational gap
in user's expectations
and behaviors on mobile?
Or is it more of a
sea change in behavior
that cuts across generations?
And John, if you'd
like to go first?
JOHN KNEELAND: Sure,
I think it is--
well, I'm going to do
that annoying answer
where it's both.
I think, it's effecting
how everyone works.
You've got new apps
with new behaviors.
The degree to which
it's, I guess,
creating a true
change in how you act
depends on how much of a
lifetime of past behaviors
you have.
If you're in your
40s or 50s, you
have half a century of
behaviors and experiences
that you're grafting
on to a new app--
a new way of meeting people.
Whereas if you're
younger, in my case
I sort of came into age as
this was also coming into age.
Or if you're another
decade younger than I am--
which is depressing-- it's
really all you've ever known.
And I've found I think the
degree to which it is changing
is directly tied to how
much experience pre-digital,
pre-mobile, pre-social you had.
JENI FISHER: Mm hm, great.
KEMAL UGUR: So when it
comes to our audience,
which is quite young--
so kids and teens--
we can see that they're
really the pro-users
and they're digital
natives compared to users
close to my age, for example.
They can really use all
the nitty-gritty details
of the tools we provide to them.
So definitely when it comes
to these younger generations,
you can see that they are much
more mobile-first and much more
digital native compared
to the older generation.
JENI FISHER: Great.
ROJHAN AHMADI: Yeah, so I will
be talking now about the older
people, though our app, of
course, has also younger ones.
But regarding the old people,
we have this aging population
in general in society.
And in Germany, for example,
20% of the population
is 65 years old or older.
And you need to
imagine that by 2030,
every third German citizen
will be 65 years old or older.
So the demographics
are changing a lot.
And these guys are different
than these young hipsters
that we have right now a
lot of times in the apps.
So with them, for
example, there's
two things that I think
are a lot different.
So one thing is perception.
The other thing is understanding
computer interfaces.
For perception-- of
course as you age,
your ability to see
things, to perceive things,
is not as strong anymore as
it was when you were young.
So that for example, for our app
we once built a version of it--
brain training app--
specifically for the elderly.
And we did this in
cooperation with a company
that provided a rent--
rest houses-- rest homes.
So there, we had to take
care of the visuals.
For example, some colors
cannot be perceived as good.
So you have to take care not
only of increasing font sizes,
but also changing the
assets of your app.
And that's some things
that we look at.
JENI FISHER: So it sounds like
everyone here should definitely
anticipate that aging
audience and think
about how you can prepare
as well with your product.
So for most of you, you are
not your target audience.
So how do you make sure that
you're building products that
really meet their user needs?
KEMAL UGUR: So
maybe I can start.
So for us, we have a big
beta tester user base.
And we have some
internal people closer
to that demographics and age
that talks with them almost
every day.
So we get a lot of feature
requests from our beta testers.
And sometimes we bring new
features and they fine tune,
and they give us some insights
that we don't really knew
beforehand.
And also, we look at how
they use the existing
features of our app.
And we get ideas to make
certain parts more efficient
or bring new features based
on what they actually do.
So it's really the constant
communication-- very close
communication-- with
these active star
users of our community.
JENI FISHER: Great.
So how about you, John?
JOHN KNEELAND: I
think there's sorts
of two parts of the
flow of information
that you need to
look at and adjust
to deal with people who are in
a very different demographic
than yourself.
The first is the distance
from the entire world
up to my ears and eyes.
And then, the second
bit of distance--
which is so much smaller
and yet so much harder--
is the distance from
there to my brain,
and actually understanding it
and internalizing these things.
In the first case, I think
Bumble is fortunate-- well,
not fortunate.
They tried really hard
and they succeeded--
in building up a
incredibly powerful network
of young people around
university campuses
and in other parts of
life around that age
to encourage them to use
the product, to get feedback
from them.
And the workforce
of Bumble itself
is also predominantly female
and five to 10 years younger
than I am.
And so I'm fortunate
that there's
no shortage of data
coming in, along,
of course, with all the
wonderful analytics tools we
get from Google and like to look
at how they're using the app.
But the second part
though, was the sea change
and realizing that you are--
as the product manager--
you are not building
something for yourself.
You are a servant of the
company and its customers.
And you truly have to listen to
these people, who even if they
are younger than you, they don't
have all the degrees that you
do, or the life
experience you do,
they have an experience
that is every bit as valid--
in the case of this
particular product,
more valid and more important.
So I think those
two chunks are what
you have to deal with
and focus on the most.
JENI FISHER: Great.
ROJHAN AHMADI: Yeah, what
we look at-- in addition
to, of course, the data--
what's interesting to us
is what our customer care
teams tells us.
So their people call
us, and then they
have questions on the product.
And in these cases, you get
this qualitative feedback.
While you listen how they
talk, you see that they--
for example, the old people--
they really don't understand
the computer interfaces.
This is not natural to them.
For example, you would
listen to something like--
you would ask them, so
what is your browser?
How do you open up a website?
And then they would
say, what is a browser?
So then you would
ask them, OK, how
do you get into the internet?
And they would say,
well, with Google.
And they don't mean Chrome,
they mean the search engine.
So they don't really
get the concept of that.
And also, they don't get
the concept of an app store.
So this is what
we have right now.
Of course they learn,
but they didn't grow up
with these things, so it
takes some time for them
to get this in their head.
JENI FISHER: So taking into
account what you've all just
said about how you're building
for people that are slightly
different to yourselves,
what impact does this have
on the way that you think
about your product roadmapping
technologies to build in?
KEMAL UGUR: So
one thing I didn't
know before I started
the company is
how much these young
generation was creative
and how much they have this
internal creative engine that
is looking for ways
to show to the world.
So basically now,
we're all doubling down
on building these creative
tools so that they can--
the audience can-- show
off their creativity.
So using all these new
hardware features helps a lot
from Google, and really
trying to translate it
to an easy-to-use
fashion for our audience.
JOHN KNEELAND: I think
in the case of Bumble,
it's forced me to
re-evaluate assumptions
that I wouldn't have even--
it wouldn't have even occurred
to me that there's a different
way of doing things now.
I think one of the most
concrete examples I have is
when we were in the process
of building Bumble Bizz--
which was released on
Android today in Germany.
Go download it and play with it.
A business networking twist
on Bumble to do more than just
meet people for dating--
we needed to find a way
of importing your jobs
and your work history or
education history into the app.
And I think anyone
of age 29 or higher
would just automatically
think, well obviously,
you go to LinkedIn--
clear as day.
It's like going to Google
for a search, you just do it.
Or I guess in the case of
Germany, you'd use Xing--
Xing-- that one.
But in the case of
these people, when
I went to share these plans
with my younger colleagues--
I mean, it wasn't so bad that
they said, what's LinkedIn.
They did know what LinkedIn
was, but that was something
that old people use.
And that was just so
mind boggling to me
because how could you not
use a networking thing?
How are you going to find a job?
Shrug.
Wow.
So we had to
re-evaluate of the core.
How are we going to get--
given our limited time
to get this done--
how do we get this in?
In the end, we
went with Facebook
because they're are apparently
just telling everything
to Facebook.
I think now in
another five years,
we're going to find that the
18-year-olds in five years
are going to be not
even on Facebook.
I don't know, we'll pull it
from Snapchat or something.
ROJHAN AHMADI: Well,
for our roadmap
there's, for example, one
quite interesting project on it
for the elderly.
It's about digitalizing
dementia assessments.
And we do this in
a collaboration
with the [? charity ?]
clinics, the German Institute
of Artificial Intelligence.
The project is also funded
by the German Ministry
of Education and Research.
And this is a long-term
project, as you can hear.
And for digitalizing
dementia assessment,
we look at how it's done
right now in the clinics.
And there, the patient
talks to the doctor,
the doctor asks some
things, and based on this,
the doctor calculates
a score that
goes into dementia assessment.
So as you can see, this
is a natural conversation.
It's not a strange
computer interface.
So we hope a lot in the
natural language processing,
so that we can replace
these kind of things
with assistance
that can then lead
the conversation
with the patient
and assess this
risk in dementia.
And on top of that, it
will be even more reliable.
Because right now for some tests
in dementia assessment, one out
of 10 times, the doctor
calculates it wrong.
So that's quite important
to do this right
and to offer the right
interface to the old people.
JENI FISHER: Great.
And so there's growing awareness
that technology has the power
to do good and also to do bad.
And so of course,
do you feel that you
have a real responsibility
towards being mindful
of your users and their
overall well-being?
KEMAL UGUR: So when it
comes to-- especially
for kids and teens,
we try to make
the community as safe
as possible and suitable
for their age.
And we have a lot
of tools internally
that we use to moderate
against, for example, bullying.
Something that I learned also,
after I founded this company,
was bullying was a big
problem in this demographics.
So we have both
community-powered tools,
where people can flag up certain
comments or certain profiles,
and we have internal
people looking at things.
Adult content we thought was
going to be a big problem.
We had all these tools
to filter those out,
but that didn't turn out to be
as big as a bullying problem.
So definitely.
I mean, people nowadays--
this is where they spend
most of their time.
And when we see
all these reports
where when they get a
bad comment from a person
that they don't
know, they feel down.
We get comments
from their parents
that now their kids are
crying or not feeling bad.
So there's all these.
And we're not still there yet.
There's a lot of
things to still to do.
But definitely I think
as app developers,
we have this
responsibility to protect
or have a safe environment.
JOHN KNEELAND: I
absolutely think
that we, as companies and
the people behind them,
have a responsibility to be
custodians of our users' time
and responsible for
their quality of life,
especially with
the younger ones.
Because again,
they're just coming
in to digital
technology in life.
And anything we do
is going to play
a much stronger
role in determining
how they go through life
than it would for say,
someone in their
40s, or 30s, or 50s--
sort of a great power,
great responsibility thing.
And within that though, I
think it isn't necessarily
against your
self-interest to do so.
It's not just the
right thing to do.
I think it's also,
in most cases,
the best thing to do
for your business.
If you pursue pointless
vanity metrics,
like the number of minutes
somebody spends in your app,
then yeah, you'd
optimize to just try
to always distract
them, always get them
at their most vulnerable
point, and try to get them in--
which might be great
for that metric,
but it's not great for them.
And maybe it's not great
for more important metrics,
like how much they convert
to being a paid customer.
In the case of Bumble,
we know from the data
there are certain
times of the day
and of the week when engagement
is the most valuable.
There are actual times of
day when people are more
likely to be swiping right.
It's definitely
not Monday morning.
And we build around that.
And I think we found that even
if you optimize for the highest
quality engagement
as opposed to just
the most engagement
possible, you'll
have an experience
that is better
for you and your
bottom line, and also
better for them and the
society that we all live in.
ROJHAN AHMADI:
Well, I also think
we're responsible, of course--
especially coming
from a health company.
And so we should
not give users--
we should not help them
build unhealthy habits.
Yeah, of course, we take
the time of our users,
but it should be reasonable.
And right now, of course, the
incentive for us developers
is to, more short-term, take
the maximum amount of time
that we can.
And this can lead to
establishing unhealthy habits.
However, if really AI is
going to revolutionize health,
and if there will be massive
amounts of data and user
tracking, then what if
the future AI assistant
actually will be able to reveal
unhealthy habits to users.
So helping them to see
where they are actually
maybe spending too much time.
If this works out,
then of course,
we developers will
have more incentive
to help them build a--
establish a healthy
relationship with us
and not an unhealthy one.
JENI FISHER: And I fully agree.
I think having that
user-centric approach to design
is not only good, of
course, for your users,
but even more so for
your bottom line as well.
And so what would
be your number one
piece of advice to
developers on dealing
with the generational gap?
KEMAL UGUR: I mean, I cannot
talk with all the generations
and demographics, but I can
only speak the audience that
I'm very familiar with,
which are these youngsters.
And they're digital natives.
They can use your product in
ways that you cannot maybe
imagined or you haven't
imagined before you released it.
So try to keep it as
flexible as possible.
And try to get
feedback very quickly.
They are very eager
to provide feedback.
And they feel engaged, and they
feel part of the community,
so don't be scared
to ask their feedback
and be engaged with the app.
As what we found was
they are more than
willing to help the developer,
especially if they like the app
and if they like the product.
JENI FISHER: Great.
What about you, John?
JOHN KNEELAND: As
succinctly as possible--
talk less and listen more.
Being less succinct, I would
say it is important to--
when you do talk,
start with questions,
and make them
open-ended questions.
I think there are
certain dynamics of age,
and status, and gender, that
if you start with a statement,
it can bias what
sorts of answers
you're getting
from these people.
So I think it's
very important to--
when you are asking
these questions-- make
them questions, make
them open-ended.
And you'll be
surprised where they go
and glad you found out, instead
of developing it and finding
out the hard way.
ROJHAN AHMADI: So what I
would suggest for the future
is really to start
just understanding
the demographical change.
Start understanding that
these old people will come.
And right now, they're maybe at
their desktop or their laptops
using web applications.
But as they grow
more into mobile
and into whatever kind of
technologies we will have,
it makes sense to
learn how they think,
and what abilities they have,
and what kind of interfaces--
for example, natural
language processing--
we can offer them to
enable also older people
to use our products.
JENI FISHER: Great.
So that's it for my questions.
So now, I'd like to hand
it over to the audience
to ask any questions as well.
Thank you.
Any questions?
JOHN KNEELAND: Guess
we've solved everything.
JENI FISHER: Yeah.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
So judging from the fact that
people who are 14 years old
are, kind of, still
don't know who
they're going to become in
three or in four years--
and the same happens with
people who when there are 70,
they don't know who they're
going to be in five years--
how do you compute
customer lifetime value
in these circumstances?
ROJHAN AHMADI: So
calculating customer lifetime
value for old people--
this is what you're about?
AUDIENCE: Both for young
and for old, I guess.
It's just the general
idea of how do you
deal with the uncertainty
in that age group?
ROJHAN AHMADI: You
mean the uncertainty
that they will be alive or what?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, that
in particular but--
I mean, like their
retirement fund
could go bust
because of the bank.
And people who are 14
years old, they still
don't have any money
right now, but maybe
they will have it later.
ROJHAN AHMADI: Well, I can just
tell about the older people--
that these are the most
loyal ones actually.
Because once they
are your customers,
they actually are not
interested in exploring
all of the different
options that they can do.
It's also a cognitive
overload, of course.
So also, we know that
old people are a lot more
sticking to their commitments--
to their own commitments.
Trust is a lot more
important to them.
So once they find that you
are a trustworthy partner,
you actually have longer
lifetime values with those
then with the younger ones,
who just jump from one app
to the next.
That's what I can tell
about the older ones.
KEMAL UGUR: For
the young ones, I
think the customer lifetime
value is a difficult thing
to compute anyway.
So we basically use the same
techniques that everyone use,
so we don't do anything
specific for younger ones.
But what Rojhan mentioned
about the younger ones
is quite true-- that they can
switch from different apps
if they get bored.
So what we do is try
to keep it fresh.
We try to make weekly releases.
Try to bring new content all the
time, so that the younger ones,
they're always thinking that
the app is always fresh,
so that they don't
switch that quickly.